صحيح نعم هذه هي الطائره الثانيه التي
تغادر مباشره من مطار الملك خالد الدولي
في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض الى مطار حلب
داخل الاراضي السوريه والتاسعه بالنسبه
للجسر الجوي السعودي الذي يقوم باغاثه
المتضررين جراء زلزال الذي حدث في سوريا
وتركيا تحديدا هذه الطائره سوف تحمل في
الشحنتها الثانيه اكثر من 45 طن من
المستلزمات النوعيه وعندما نتحدث تحديدا
عن المستلزمات النوعيه هي مستلزمات طبيه
وكذلك حليب للاطفال وايضا اسره طبيه وايضا
خيام وايضا بعض السلال الغذائيه وتحديدا
هذه الاحتياجات او هذه الشحنه هي خصصت بعد
ان رفع ممثلي وشركاء مركز الملك سلمان
لغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه داخل الاراضي
السوريه الاحتياجات الضروريه العاجله
اللازمه
المتضررين جراء الزلزال داخل الاراضي
السوريه اذا العربيه الان تواكب عمليه نقل
هذه الشحنات داخل الطائره المخصصه والمعده
لمغادره مغادرتها الى
مطار حلب والتي سوف تقلع من مطار الملك
خالد الدولي في تمام الساعه السادسه صباحا
بتوقيت المحلي السعودي وسوف تكون مده
الرحله قرابه الثلاث ساعات ونصف الساعه
بينما ايضا